bonjour monsieur Lemoine Dr STC va
commencer les manoeuvre et puis un Mg x
3 j'ai besoin des signes vitaux on va
parler de stats nouvelle quotidienne
vous incarnez Emmanuel Saint-Cyr sur
jean-tolos je suis tout un défi 120
épisodes à peu près 150 jours de
tournage pourquoi avoir accepté ce défi
là je pense que moi j'aime beaucoup les
défis dans la vie
j'en ai fait plus de
l'année passée j'avais fait une scène de
bataille dans une douche en prison dans
un tournage en France nu c'est pas pour
exciter personne là parce que c'est pas
ça mais c'est le niveau d'intensité
d'exigence je me dis mais pourquoi
pourquoi
mais mais c'est sûr qu'une fois que tu
le fais que tu réussis à le faire que tu
trouves l'énigme dans ta tête de comment
je vais réussir à faire ça cette chose
là
ça devient addictif aussi c'est ça qui
nous amène plus loin aussi évidemment
puis qui nous fait découvrir des zones
de nous-mêmes qu'on connaissait pas donc
ça ça fait partie de ça le niveau de de
vitesse de travail il faut bien le dire
la quantité de texte à apprendre
où est ma fille vous parlez de défi mais
des grands défis dans votre vie ça a été
de passer près de 10 ans en France à
jouer sur des plateaux européens vous
avez travaillé pour des séries comme
Versailles la forêt la bulle vampire des
rafages ouf ouais ouais
semble-t-il que c'est le décès de votre
père qui vous a ramené à Montréal d'une
certaine façon c'est dur c'était
vraiment dur de partir et puis j'ai
revenu parce que je voulais aussi
m'occuper de ma mère et de être proche
de ma soeur puis de ma famille puis en
fait ça fait sens complètement ça a été
comme un révélation
que je savais c'était sous-jacent en moi
le que j'avais le désir peut-être de
revenir mais
c'est mon père m'a fait ce cadeau là
d'une certaine façon on peut le voir
comme ça de vraiment faire le pas puis
tu fais ah en fait je suis très bien de
retour à Montréal comment ça s'est fait
parce que vous êtes un modèle pour
d'autres comédiens comédiennes du Québec
qui voudraient faire ça en France
ben c'est flatteur ben écoute c'est
surtout le film les films de Xavier là
c'est vraiment Xavier qui est Xavier
Dolan c'est grâce à lui et c'est à cause
de leur enseigny ways on est allé à
Cannes qui m'ont mis après c'est à
partir de leur enseigné ouest que là les
agents m'ont en France m'ont dit qu'il y
avait un intérêt
[Musique]
cela non officiellement Robert
j'ai besoin de
[Musique]
ce moment-là je me rappelle que je
m'étais dit j'avais envie de le faire je
m'étais vraiment fait coacher aussi pour
pour faire ce film
c'est une coche de je prends en charge
cette affaire là d'être aussi bon c'est
ton personnage qui est dans le titre de
la série ça dit quelque chose aussi ça
parce que tu es prête à porter sur tes
épaules c'est que oui ça a été ça a été
une série super importante
je boucle la boucle avec la quotidienne
stat qui débute très bientôt le 12
septembre vous dites j'ai un peu peur
mais je carbure à l'adrénaline vous
faites la course à pied comment ça se
vit ce besoin d'adrénaline là parce que
cette semaine je me disais ça dans la
durée c'est correct je le vois que je
correcte dans la durée mais vous êtes un
coureur coureur de fond donc je pense
que vous pouvez comprendre il y a
vraiment quelque chose dans l'endurance
dans la dans la répétition parce que
c'est une vraie discipline méditation
aussi
ça répond à ce projet-là j'ai bien hâte
d'avoir start merci beaucoup merci après
on va l'envoyer au scan Sofia est-ce que
tu peux appeler le bloc opératoire
[Musique]